خلال احد عشر عاما اعتبر الرجل الاكثر
اثراء في افريقيا وبقيت مجموعته
الاستثماريه واحده من الاكبر في غرب
افريقيا انه النيجيري اليكو دانغوتي الذي
جنى خلال ثلاثه عقود فقط ثروه تقدر بنحو
13 مليار دولار فما سر هذه الثروه ولد
اليكو دانغوتي في نيجيريا عام
1957 لعائله ثريه فجده الاكبر كان تاجرا
كبيرا واغنى رجلا في غرب افريقيا حتى
وفاته فيما ان والده رجل اعمال وسياسي وهو
ما دفعه ليفكر بالتجاره مبكرا حيث كان
يشتري علب السكاكر ويبيعها لزملائه في
المدرسه لكسب المال بعد ان انهى دراسته
الثانويه سافر الى مصر حيث درس اداره
الاعمال في جامعه الازهر بالقاهره ثم عاد
الى بلاده مع حلم كبير لبدء نشاطه التجاري
حيث اقترض من قريب له مبلغا بسيطا واسس
شركه صغيره لتجاره الاسمنت كان ذلك في عام
1977 قبل ان يقوم بتحويلها الى مجموعه
دانغوت جروب ومن ثم توسيع مجالاتها لتشمل
السكر والاسماك والحليب والدقيقه والارز
الى اخره حققت المجموعه خلال سنوات قليله
نجاحات كبرى ولكن الاختراق الاكبر حدث
عندما اضافت غايه معالجه الاغذيه وكذلك
تصنيع الاسمنت ما رفع من ايراداتها التي
جاء السواد الاعظم منها عبر تجاره السكر
في نيجيريا كما باتت شركته تملك اكبر معمل
لتكرير السكر في افريقيا وثالث اكبر معمل
في جميع انحاء العالم الجزء الاخر الذي
قام بتطويره اليكو هو السيطره على خط
التوريد لمصانع المشروبات الغازيه
والحلويات الاكبر في البلاد مع الوقت
اصبحت شركه اليكو تصدر العديد من المواد
الغذائيه في جميع انحاء القاره بما في ذلك
[موسيقى]